Let's at the Joe Rogan experience,
like the network will let us do anti thing.
We've been on the show for moving on the network for four years.
The only time they've ever killed the show was we want to do something about the
Ncaa,
about how the NCAA shouldn't kill,
I shouldn't kill.
Sorry.
Shit.
It should pay athletes,
right?
Well,
in the case of football is going,
yeah,
yeah.
We'd talk about that all the time.
I think it is one of the craziest fucking scams in,
in all of money.
Let College sports or
it's unbelievable.
I'm making so much money off those kids.
When you watch those things,
every single person's getting paid,
you know,
everybody's getting paid.
The Guy,
best players,
the guy bringing water to the announcers are getting paid except for the
players.
Right.
And the guy who literally,
I'm blanking on his name,
but the guy who created the system,
right,
who like formed the NCAA later when he left,
he compared it to plantation slavery.
He was like,
this is like slavery.
What I invented,
you know,
there's no justification for it at all.
It is bananas.
Uh,
we want to do that topic for a college episode.
We pitched that to true TV.
Uh,
you know what airs on true TV every March,
March,
math,
March madness.
They said no.
They said,
they said,
and here's,
here's how I live with myself.
I say,
look,
I will never take a no until it's the only absolute answer I can get.
So they said,
no.
I say,
I really want to do it.
Tell me know again.
You know,
they told me no again.
I was like,
if the president of the network tells me no,
then I'm not doing it.
And the president of network told me no,
because that's the guy who I could write it and he could tell the episode.
Wow.
Yeah,
that's true.
That's true.
Really.
It shouldn't have NCAA on,
you're worried about,
they're worried about pissing off the NCAA books.
Yeah.
Pissed off those money grubbing thieves wheelie man,
those athletic kids.
I'm with you all these month.
People are paying money to see those fucking kids.
That shit drives me crazy.
Exploiting of young athletes in,
in college is anchors.
It is one of the ones that drives me because I got into it with Joey Diaz who
explained to me,
cause Joey used to be a bookie and he really understands gambling.
He was explaining to me how much money gets donated to the schools by people who
used to go to them.
He goes,
it's insane.
And he sent it and most of it is based on the performance that the school has in
college sports at these people who are,
you know,
I'm a fucking,
Blah Blah Blah.
I went to school there and I'm there till I.
Dot.
I fucking go team.
Yeah.
These assholes throw shit.
Tons of money and there's thousands of them all throughout history.
Yeah.
Years and years guys have been donating for 25 fucking years and when the team
wins the championship,
they give them a bonus to add even more.
Right?
Yes.
Who doesn't get the money as the kid?
Fucking people
who play the game.
All they have to do so well.
If you get through here,
you're going to do education and then you get to go to pro sports.
Yeah.
How many of them make it,
especially in football,
almost none.
Almost.
No,
but look at it.
What are the numbers?
What does it like?
I wonder what the numbers are guys who sign up for college football,
who make it first of all,
with a body that's functional after four years of 600 fucking pound dudes,
slam magazine.
Not that big,
but giant,
giant dude slamming into you.
You know,
five days
we did a,
we did an episode on football and the the concussion thing,
and it's not just concussions,
right?
It's like just the little hits,
It's just the routine tackles.
You know what I mean?
What happens every single time you do that,
your brain,
you got to think of it this way.
Your brain is riding your,
your skull is the car.
Your brain's a passenger.
Your brain doesn't have a seatbelt,
right?
Every time you run into somebody,
boom,
your brain slides forward a little bit cause it's not wearing a seat belt bumps
into the front of your skull and bounces back,
right?
And even if it doesn't cause a concussion,
it causes a little,
a little hurt every single time,
right?
And so you can never get a concussion do that over and over and over again,
and you're going to end up with CTE.
And so some trauma happens in soccer players.
Yeah,
it's an issue in soccer.
And those kids or those kids are hurting themselves,
you know,
uh,
and they're not getting paid for it.
Jamie wrote here in football,
out of 73,557 NCAA participants,
approximate number who are draft eligible is down to 16,346 and now down to
draft picks,
it's 256 so 256 out of 73,000 make it to draft,
pick
1.6% make it from the NCAA to the majors.
1.6% ridiculous.
Ncaa to major pro,
1.6% that is fucking crazy.
Let's be honest,
these kids are not getting a full education as polos.
Baseball is almost 10% way more teams with like miners and all that kind of
crazy though.
It's wild.
So I was 10% that's weird.
Well,
the there'll,
but that's,
oh,
that's 10% of from draft eligible to drafted the major battles,
not even the participants because look that's,
that's a 35 k seven,
seven k or draft eligible and then seven joint seven are drafted.
Right.
But look how low the number is in terms of uh,
baseball participants versus footballs.
Half less than half.
And yet they have way higher percentage.
This is our writings themselves.
We look at charts also.
The thing is like with baseball,
you don't get hit,
right?
Yeah.
Unless you get hit by a ball.
Most of the time your injuries just from running or sliding and stuff like that.
Yeah.
Well you can get,
yeah,
you can get hit in the head with a baseball.
So much safer.
If I had a kid and the kid was thinking of like baseball,
football or basketball,
be like,
we'll take that football out of the fucking equation.
You've got two choices.
It was don't do it.
Just don't do it.
You're not gonna make it.
The very few people that make it out of there without like serious injury.
It's like it's not worth it.
It's just not especially,
yeah.
Do you look at that 75,000 number?
If you look at,
uh,
for how many kids are playing in the NCAA now think about how many kids are
playing high school football.
I don't know the number,
but it's gotta be 10 times that
you showing us Sherry,
me,
this kid is going to be,
he's the Heisman trophy winner and he already has been drafted to the major
league baseball,
but he's also projected to potentially be in a top five NFL picks.
Whoa.
There's like a big discussion on what should he do.
It's up to him obviously,
but players like Deion Sanders,
so I've been in both leagues and I've done both at the same time as like play
baseball,
baseball man.
Well that's better for your life because you're less,
you're less likely to,
to like,
yeah,
I have brain damage.
Do you ever talk to a fucking baseball player that's retired?
It's like talking to a regular person.
He still doesn't,
he still wants to be the quarterback.
They'll,
you know,
I mean,
well,
can be a basketball player.
Those guys clearly have the best of it,
like out of all the major sports basketball players,
because they,
I don't know about that because it's a much more grueling schedule physically.
First of all,
you're running and shooting every night.
You're sprinting,
you're doing all these different things,
and baseball is so much more leisurely.
Okay.